I want to ask you something a picture of
you I saw recently it's a picture of you
with Kathy Griffin explain what was I
mean I can see what's happening here
yeah but why did she know you were there
yeah do you think I love this bride you
snuck into a changing exactly what did
not what was happening here um it was we
were doing a photo shoot for a magazine
and we were kind of crossing paths like
I was finishing my photo shoot and she
was coming for hers and she was like oh
you know what we should do and she was
telling me this as she was taking off
her clothes she's like we should
recreate the Janet Jackson pose and then
she was like naked and I was like well I
got to do this now because she's just
revealed her breasts to the whole crew
so I was like out behind her it was like
okay here we go
you don't look thrilled here
[Laughter]
and I'm on the wood this is about to get
shot
it's actually the how I reacted yeah my
love life but did you I mean but you're
an actor you're comfortable situations I
was fine with it I it was kind of the
first time that that's happened to me
having breasts my hands that is not
Cathy I mean Cathy I've get busy all the
time but um actually and then a few
weeks later I I was doing a stunt with
Sofia vergata on set and I had to help
her off of a chair and she had to fall
and I and we were practicing at night
she fell into my arms and I just got
full breasts and I say oh I'm sorry
about that and like all the grips and
all like the stage hands were like like
this is so wasted but I can I can
confirm that they are real yeah I know
that much you just got slammed with us
Oh Sofia Vergara breasts yes yes I know
I know my wife